On Julie,
what's going on?
This is my last night on petty a fucking awesome time.
Um,
so it was a little grumpy on Monday.
You know what I mean?
That's what happens when you drink outside in the sun all day to fucking tennis
match bunt.
But of rich concen you,
I watched the whole fucking youtube video of just,
you know,
tennis people losing their shit.
It's like they're not,
they were upset that their,
they want to win the championship.
I like when they smashed their racket and act like they give a fuck.
I don't want to see somebody out there with the Goddamn White Hanky.
Right.
Anyways,
I already talked about this shit on the last podcast.
Uh,
this is the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast just before Friday.
Um,
you know,
what do you,
what are you doing?
Huh?
Fuck.
Are you doing,
I had a birthday actually today,
which will be yesterday by the time you hear this shit.
Um,
and I am,
let's see again,
finally say it right.
Count on set.
47 years old,
dude.
Whoa.
Getting up there.
Um,
I had a fucking awesome day.
Uh,
I,
me and my lovely wife walked up to,
uh,
the Eiffel Tower,
right.
And,
uh,
I realized,
you know,
as I'm trying to learn,
some French over here,
which is,
you know,
I,
I'm at that level where I'm like,
hello,
Mr. I would like a rotisserie chicken if you please.
And you know,
right off the bat,
I mean,
they know,
nobody talks like that.
Even if you pronounced it perfectly.
The like,
what is this guy a fucking robot?
Like nobody talks like that.
You gotta get to the point where we're like,
hey,
what's going on man?
How are you?
Uh,
let me get the a rotisserie chicken and let me hit,
been in beer over there,
however you just normally talk.
So then there's some other shit that you need to have to say,
like at one point,
um,
you know,
we're walking along the Sandra,
Sandra or whatever the fuck you call it.
And,
uh,
on the right bank is,
is Lulu and all of that shit and all those shops,
it's basically there are times square,
you know,
it's all just fucking,
tourists like me and,
and,
and just fucking people who have money who want to show it off.
You know that road Dayo drive horse shit when people just walk around with a
bunch of fucking patent leather horseshit,
you know,
doing the duck lip fucking selfies.
Like that's what that is.
If you get out of that,
it's great.
So we're on our way over there.
It's like an asshole.
I'm an old man.
CanNot set,
I don't want to fucking walk over there.
So there's one of those bike Rick shot things.
So I say to that dude,
I'm like,
uh,
you know,
Columbian Pura dub above Ba.
And He,
and he said fucking like,
what'd he say?
He said won't sank.
And I'm like,
come on man.
25 bucks just to go a thing a little bit at the fucking thing,
right?
So he takes us over the bridge,
whatever he's pedaling and stuff and he stinks.
Smells would be oh no,
cause he French's cause he pedals around two full grown adults all God damn day.
And uh,
so we get to the other side,
you know,
and this mother Fucker,
I gave him 25 euros and he goes no,
he's like each,
it's like get the fuck outta here.
What are you going to 20 bucks each.
So they're,
I'm not giving you a fucking 20 bucks each,
you know,
but,
but the bill,
you seen all his shit and uh,
what,
what I needed to know how to say there was key a day con Ra cholerae right?
Key a day Connery,
which that is bullshit.
And then if he continued talking to me,
I should've said busy at the man.
Fuck your mother and I should have walked away.
But I know not to say it.
So I gave him 20 euros and 10 American.
See that if it cost me $10 USA,
cause I did not say kid they corner conair how do make sure you guys say this
right?
Let me have this fucking this how you say fuck your mother.
Stay with me.
This is beds data.
Mad As fuck you mother.
You've got to save that one.
There's no reason to fucking,
you don't come out of the gate with that.
You start off with,
well,
it'd be a good night.
Okay.
Yeah.
The Goodna he ga the Guarneri.
Let me say that's bullshit,
right?
20 no fucking phone saying each.
And that's when I go key a Dick Connery.
And then when he keeps fucking talking,
Dan,
you dropped the bomb.
This is what she said.
[inaudible] fuck your mother and you walk away.
What are you going to do to me?
Huh?
You gonna slap me near Oulu
whatever.
Fuck him.
He took 10 American that's worth like $3 euros.
So I got out of it for fucking drunk tweeting,
right?
That Carolyn said,
that's not too bad.
I think.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
excited to be back and I'm fucking Jones and so bad to do some standup.
Um,
I had a fucking such an awesome time over here.
I'm all rested up and all that shit and I'm ready to go into was hilarious.
Today was I wake up and,
uh,
and you're not going to see this video,
but my wife videotape me.
I said,
I am 47 years old.
I gotta get,
I gotta hit the deck here.
I got to try to bang up 47 pushups.
Uh,
it was an ugly scene.
I did it.
I actually did 50.
I did 50,
but I,
when I finished the 50,
I like fucking rolled over on my back and did that thing.
You know,
you cover your eyes with your fuck in the crook of your arm and was just,
just,
you would've thought I was,
you know that person that runs a marathon and they get like a mile away from the
finish line and they're shitting because their bowels have failed.
Like that's how fucking exhausted I was.
Um,
it's bad.
I'm a big fucking French pastry at this point.
I,
I gotta do something about this shit and I'm only home for four days.
When I get back,
before I get on the bus,
Gus and me and Joe Barton,
nick are going to be tying the west coast.
So,
uh,
there's going to be plenty of crown royals on that one.
So I don't know what I'm going to do here.
I got to hit the salads or something.
Um,
well you could say no bill.
You could say,
hey,
you know,
I'm not drinking on this one,
but where's the fun in that?
You know,
where is the fun in that?
That's what I,
that's how I look at it.
You know,
if you know baby seals are going to wash up onto the beach and no one gives a
fuck,
I mean,
it's,
it's gonna be over.
You know what somebody said to me the other day was telling me,
you got to have a kid.
And I was like,
I know.
And he goes,
no,
but you can't just have one.
You've got to have to,
it's like,
it's like douchebag
or you're watching the news,
you know,
got to have to do you really,
you don't think there's enough fucking people taking a shit every day?
Huh?
Thrown another fucking plastic water bottle into the end of the ocean.
Okay.
You should be looking at me going,
thank you.
Thank you for not having fucking any and there's two less conscious walker.
I'm in the fucking world,
right?
Everyone should have one from here on out until it tapers off.
And everybody will be like,
well,
what's the ramification of an entire generation of only child's?
Well,
how much worse can they do then what we've done,
right?
Ah,
Jesus old Billy soapbox here.
Look at him.
He's,
he's banging his fucking Bible.
Yeah.
I'm telling you guys this a space ship that's coming in 20,
30,
uh,
with a freckled son and God and a,
he only talks to me.
So you guys need to gather around and drink my fucking Koolaid.
How about that?
I want to start my own compound.
You guys call me father,
right?
I'll go buy a patch of fucking dirt out.
And I dunno,
God knows somewhere in Texas where it's nice and dry where it looks like the end
of the fucking world.
I know they had their floods there,
but believe me,
believe me,
when that shit's over,
it's going to go right back to the shit they've been dealing with the last three
years.
Um,
it was it three years.
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I'm doing this shit to fucking,
you know,
it's like one 13 in the morning and I got a cab to the airport at 10 30 so I
know I'm not getting up in the morning.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
I'm telling you guys,
you got to,
you got to come to Paris at some point your life and don't get all conti like
that Douche on Twitter.
Okay.
There's broke as college kids to come over here with a backpack and go all the
way through Europe.
And I remember when I was a young man,
long time ago,
I was a kid in college.
I remember thinking,
I want to do that and I never did it like an asshole.
So then I got into the real world.
Even though I got into show business,
it's still the real fucking world.
And it took me half a century,
almost 47 years before I've been starting to come over here.
So,
um,
you should definitely fucking do it cause there's a bunch of ways to do it.
You can figure it out and uh,
I'm telling you,
if you just came over here for four or five days,
you just came over with four or five days,
sat in a cafe,
you know,
had yourself a drink and just watch the fucking city go by.
It's life changing,
telling you it's fucking life change.
And everybody tries to act like you got to come over here on your own.
God Damn,
yet you don't,
I got over here telling shit jokes and strip malls.
All right,
so I don't want to hear it.
If you want to come over here,
you can definitely fucking do it.
Um,
I wish I did it a long fucking time ago.
When I think of all the fucking money I blew on doing good Dole is going to
fucking nicest is,
you know,
the dumb shit I did back in the day,
just blowing all this cash,
you know what I mean?
Plus she a young man,
you fucking young,
they can stuff here in the back of the airplane.
You shake it off.
Fucking old man like me.
I limp around for 10 days.
So,
uh,
I'm hoping,
um,
I'm hoping you guys here in some of these stories about coming over here.
You know,
maybe you don't want to come here,
maybe want to go somewhere else.
Fucking do it.
They looked before you get married and you've got kids and you're all fucking
locked down.
Just fucking,
I'm telling you figure out a way.
Stay home a couple of weekends.
I'm oversimplifying it,
but it really,
you know,
cut a plan,
get over here.
I said,
all right.
How many minutes away?
Up to at 10.
23.
All right.
What about,
I want to talk about it.
How about that?
Fucking Tampa Bay lightning.
Huh?
I saw the,
uh,
the first period and then I fell asleep.
It's just,
they just come to the games and coming on too late.
Like right now it's one 16 in the morning and I'm already on nhl.com wait for
this thing to start.
So already,
you know what's great is I don't have to watch the pregame,
cause I know what they're saying.
Know I got at science and I as got to,
it's a must win for Chicago lay.
CanNot go down three one in this series and go back to Tampa.
Wouldn't you agree?
Somebody else with a suit and a fucking pocket square.
Um,
but I got to say who,
who,
who out there other than a hardcore black,
uh,
Tampa Bay lightening fan thought the Tampa Bay was going to be up to one,
especially have to Chicago when the first fucking game in Tampa.
Um,
but who,
who's kidding,
who,
you know,
Chicago's winning tonight.
I would be absolutely.
I don't want to jinx them,
but I mean I would be shocked as a fucking fan if,
if Chicago goes back to Tampa.
Anything other than to to,
well,
what else could they be three one down one,
three?
Yeah.
Obviously though.
Um,
I think the answer tonight and uh,
Oh man,
I hope it goes seven.
I hope it goes seven cause to tonight's the last game.
I'm Kinda gonna Miss.
Um,
I did see all the game too,
and I've missed all of the fucking NBA finals.
Um,
but that sounds like it's a great,
uh,
what is it?
Cavaliers are up to one against a golden state or as I like to call them
Sacramento.
And
everybody's saying,
what's his face there?
Steph curry hasn't been the same since they dropped them on the head.
I guess that's what the fuck they were talking about.
I hope that isn't the case because whoever wins,
I'd like them to,
you know,
you don't want to see what their best guy be hurt and then you win.
You know what I mean?
You want to beat them at their best.
So,
um,
I'm looking forward to seeing both of those things.
I'm looking forward to seeing my dog.
I'm ready to come back and I'm ready to start this tour.
Um,
I,
I can't wait to get back.
So anyways,
what else did I want to talk about?
Jesus Christ.
My fucking head is swimming here.
Hang on,
hang on.
Hang on.
Father's Day's coming up,
right?
Do I got to talk about that Shit,
ma?
What do you mean not yet?
Really want?
What's too early?
It isn't too early cause according to the advertiser and then we're advertising
the man.
Great.
Nia,
the man,
great.
Hey,
attention grill masters.
If you have father
is a man of exquisite taste,
there is no finer gift than the ultimate steak house experience.
Oh,
you couldn't take him to the steak house?
No,
we're going to give him a man.
Great.
And tell them to cook his own state
that they're building them up like he's the most interesting man in the world.
This is now I'm just picturing some guy wearing fucking loafers in those stocks.
Grill in his backyard,
got a cigarette going or whatever.
You know he wants a good take.
Good steak,
right man.
Great is 100% cast iron.
Grill Grill grates the main brain.
What is a man?
Great.
You ask or maybe you didn't,
but I'm going to tell you anyways,
man,
grades are American made high quality 100% cast iron grill grates that sit right
on top of your existing grill grates.
In other words,
you bought a shitty little Hibachi and they're going to fix this thing for you,
right?
It's like you bought a Chevy cavalier.
You didn't even get the z 24 and now they're going to throw the biggest engineer
they can't weighing in at eight pounds a piece.
Man,
greats insured,
juicy,
tender meat with no flareups and perfect sear marks.
Every time you,
these stakes are going to taste so good,
there's going to be a couple of gold dig and Stan and on the other study of
Dad's fence,
right man,
grades patented design delivers steakhouse quality flavor right at home.
Take advantage of the Monday morning podcast,
Father's Day special and get 40% off all cast iron grates and premium
brushes@mangreat.com when fans use the code bird 21 no space B u r r two one a
or event Ale,
uh,
spend $50 or more.
This father's day with man.
Great and dad will receive a premium United States of begun tee shirt.
You see how dumb they think guys are?
Is He really gonna wear it?
Why don't you just slap them in the face with the man.
Great.
Jay,
the guy likes steak.
Can you,
can you give him some dignity?
Kind of a fucking shirt,
is that she'd give him a fucking clown nose and slap them with a rubber chicken.
Uh,
don't forget the brush man.
Greatest design.
They're long bristle brush to get down deep between each rail keeping your
grates and prime.
But why do they always got to have that dumb shit if you're grilling,
like you got to have an apron that says,
I hate Kale.
Why can't you like pork chops and a vegetable?
Don't you want that stuff to come out of your ass at some point in your life?
Um,
order.
But
I'm just seeing me.
Nothing else that's like those dummies that go on that diet,
dude.
I mean,
not the bug bacon.
The weights fallen off make.
Yeah,
he's your choke out your heart.
Alright.
Order by Monday,
June,
June 15th.
I get you a snorting on that one.
Any for guaranteed arrival by father's day,
anywhere in the United States.
Make sure to go to [inaudible] dot com and enter my coupon code,
Burt 21 at checkup.
All right,
last one lastly,
but not leastly.
Oh boy.
Here's the intro.
Everybody.
Hey,
hey.
Hey.
Dot,
dot,
dot.
Any of the pies there.
Hey,
we get their attention.
hey,
you like Mike making money,
right?
Sure.
We all do.
Here's a really cool opportunity that evidently I had to share with you
driving with Uber,
Uber,
in case you live under a fucking rock or you're over the age of 60 is that
popular smartphone APP that connects writers with drivers.
Evidently,
I take Uber a bunch.
I wasn't aware of that.
Nia,
what else do I do that Uber knows that I don't do?
I love them by the way.
Wow.
And in chatting with different drivers,
some of them have really interesting stories as to why they drive with Uber.
Why did they do this?
Near Uber is absolutely crushing it.
They're here in Paris right now.
I said this last time,
I don't take Uber because everybody's like my age and they watched fucking
comedy central and they're like,
oh yeah,
that freckled confirm that thing and now I know where you live.
And it weirds me out.
If I take a cab,
it's that low.
My friend,
I used to be neurosurgeon.
No,
I thrive in the carb.
Those guys don't give a shit and I do as hold my breath on the way.
Oh Man,
I'm there.
God,
stop what?
What generally spell?
Yeah,
and Irish people aren't drunk.
Oh,
don't you dare,
don't you.
Let me tell you some.
Anybody drives for 12 hours in a cab.
That's going to be a funk in there.
All right?
There's to be a little of Bootsy Collins up in the air,
if you know what I mean.
And it Shannon with different noise.
Okay.
Bootsy Collins,
the Bass player for Rod James Brown.
They played funk music.
Do I got to spell the whole thing out?
Oh fuck yes.
He's got some boots to get his,
I'm pitch there nothing.
What was that song when he came around?
Group is in the heart,
right?
What was the,
what was that thing he would say,
what was the thing he would say?
He had his one little know that one of the learning would say in that thing.
He be like you.
He would say something like that.
Anyway,
this is so,
this copy is so fucking dumb.
Listen,
you have a car.
All right?
Things just sitting there.
If you want to make extra money,
just become an Uber driver.
Okay?
You're going to love being your own boss.
You're going to earn some great money work whenever the fuck you want.
It's easy to stat.
He just needed a car and a license.
Driving with Uber is great for anyone who needs flexibility.
Parents,
this is a really easy way to work around your family schedule.
It's a great way to avoid your family.
Tunia you don't like the kids?
Hey,
guess what?
I love to hang out with you,
but daddy's got his second job.
Are you fucking somebody else?
Nah,
I'm just driving around
students.
You can make some extra money between classes.
No more stripping.
Ladies.
Now's the primetime to Cashin.
Uh,
driving with Uber.
You'll thank me for telling you how to get paid every week.
I could be getting into your car when you drive with Uber.
If I'm with you,
I will be called to action.
You got a car and a license.
Put them both to work for you and start earning serious life changing money
today.
Sign up to drive with Uber.
Visit drive with uber.com that's drive with uber.com.
Drive with uber.com they go,
you fucking do this job all the every month.
All the money you make from this you put into your,
I'm going to this fucking,
I dunno,
buyout Nalco to Bali.
You fucking have a joint.
They stick in jail for fucking 30 years,
don't you?
Have you talked about that boogie board
and on my birthday?
Yeah,
I mentioned it.
It's your birthday.
It's yard,
right then.
Yes it is.
It was.
It's one 25 in the morning and now begins the slow march to Karen sweets.
Not to test canter on sweet.
Come on.
What does this fucking hockey game starting any,
by the way,
I'm staying up all night watching this thing.
Are you really well,
I'm going to stay up as long as I can.
We still have a bottle of wine left.
I'd have finished that bottle of red.
Why don't they put wine in a cancer shock on it?
What did they put wine in a can see can shotgun it every once in a while.
Just take a fucking giant can of any wine.
He known the word not worth drinking.
Oh,
thank you,
mia.
You're so cultured.
I thought it was,
I thought it was the good stuff that is in the good stuff.
Doesn't Budweiser make a penal greenish
is how you say,
fuck your mother and French.
That's what I should have said to that guy.
The guy in the fucking rickshaw bicycle,
but there's no need to escalate it to,
well,
I should have started with this,
right?
Yeah.
I should have started with this.
Should have started with this.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's bullshit.
Yeah,
but there's really no,
then go Nomis Ja ga like,
no,
no mister.
That's bullshit.
But he say,
dude in French,
chief chief,
remember we saw that kids today are the Eiffel Tower wearing a shirt.
Then she'll dude,
how about those Gypsies that came up and tried to fucking pickpocket us?
Here's one for you.
Yeah.
When they come up to you,
when you were in a different country and like three people walk up to you with
these,
uh,
with a clipboard,
clipboard paper with a bunch of what seems like signatures on it.
And then they walk up to you immediately speaking English.
They speak English.
Yeah.
That may build this wet now.
And they just started,
it hasn't walked away immediately.
They weren't.
No,
I didn't.
I said,
I said no.
I said with a French accent and then they walked away and I started speaking
English and then one of them turned around and glared at me.
It's like,
fuck you.
You're going to be,
yeah.
So as I explained there,
let's save the Bald Eagles fucking thing.
But they're in your pockets.
Oh,
party.
That's right.
That's how you see chief chef.
So I should have been less.
Yeah,
no chef.
I was trying to talk like no cheese,
really bad dads out.
Bullshit and a dude.
It is.
Wait dude it is and then,
then I walk.
Yeah.
Fuck your mother.
Right.
You can't walk away saying fuck fucking mother cause you get punched in the back
of there.
You gotta you gotta Lock Eyes and whoever looks away first loses right.
Is that how it works now?
Cause Cause I was,
I was saying look up do it.
I added a lot of plug in Dunkin kid.
When are you looked that up?
Because clearly you're just trying to like talk like a Boston asshole.
I should have said that.
I should have said that because he wouldn't have known what it meant.
Like no,
no the,
you know,
von sank each and it'd be a door.
I gotta go to fucking donkey.
So he wouldn't have not ever had no clue what I was saying.
And eventually he has to get on with his day
has do we?
Yeah,
he was pepe Le Pew though,
wasn't he?
Oh he was.
He was and he was so near,
did you have a good time over here?
I had an amazing time.
Well,
what do you think of that kid on Silk Road?
Ooh,
on the wet road.
Silk Road.
Oh,
the kid.
The guy that got sentenced to life.
Yeah.
Well what do we,
what are you thinking?
You think he just going to fuck?
Evidently they got something here called the fucking,
there's like an underground internet,
like the dark internet.
Yeah.
Oh really?
Yeah,
the deep Internet.
It's cold.
No it isn't.
Yes,
it is actually easy because it has a regular internet that you serve,
like Wikipedia and Google and your email.
What is this called?
The dark web.
Okay,
good.
Deep Internet.
There's also,
they call it the deep,
Deep Internet.
All right,
fine.
I think that's where people like say stuff and then people just go,
oh wait,
shit.
Deep Web.
The deep web.
Okay,
you're close.
So close.
But yeah,
that's where all the illegal shit goes down.
But you really have to know the Internet,
I think too,
in order to get there.
It's not like the kind of thing.
No,
it's shady.
It's like it's like buying drugs and looking at like kitty porn.
Right,
exactly.
And then people arguing with that.
Ben Affleck is the new Batman.
Oh,
hey,
how great was that video that we watched?
There was this white kid,
right?
W D dresses up like an old man and he
kiki look like the um,
the,
the six flags.
Remember those commercials with the six flag with the old man and he'd be
dancing and doing like the running man he'd,
they did,
they did it.
People who are listening to this,
they remember those commercial,
he's have those big dumb black glasses and it was clearly like a young kid and
an old man mask and he'd be like doing the running.
Yeah,
kid wasn't,
this kid had great makeup and people thought that he thought it wasn't,
they thought it was an old man and he walks down the street late at night.
He can do all those Michael Jackson moves.
So he walks like an old man and raise these people are walking by him going the
other way.
He'll just bust out one of those moves real quick and it freaks people the fuck
out.
But the best part of the video is in the end,
he goes into this park late at night with,
there's all these,
these young black men right in their 20s than an old white man should be
terrified of.
Right?
All these racist fucking white dude said,
terrified.
He walks in right into the middle of him,
tells him all that clear out and starts busting out those moves and they went
fucking nuts.
That was the funniest thing of could they have been more supportive?
That's what was cracking me up about that.
Yeah.
They were going,
they were slapping him on his old man's ass.
Tell,
tell them to keep going.
That one dude who was jumping up and down,
my favorite one was a dude just standing on the bench with his arms up the exact
same way.
Joe Montana,
when when he would throw for a touchdown pass,
he,
he just put his arm straight up.
He was just doing that the whole time.
Like this guy is fucking killing it.
I mean,
if you're a white person and you're not laying,
we will give you the respect that you do.
But if you're lame,
I get it.
What
now?
What does that mean?
You know what it means?
No,
I don't because there's a lot of the that could go either way.
Like we're going to just say you're corny.
Get the fuck out of here or we're going to steal your bicycle.
You know,
you gotta
get a frame.
I have no,
I'm talking about,
I'm trying to bring people together with this shit.
All right.
You left it all ambiguous.
Then the black people that are listening,
they know what I'm talking about.
You know you've done that twice.
What do you mean,
where you'd say something?
I don't know what you're talking about and you're like,
yeah,
well people will listen to understand what I'm saying because I don't feel the
need to have to explain every single little thing to you.
That's not what I'm here for.
Jesus.
She wouldn't,
you didn't think that I took her to like Paris,
Virginia at this point.
You'd think they'd get a little more.
Yeah.
And ignore my birthday.
Just ended an hour and a half ago.
That's,
see,
that's what it is guys.
When she got to know it doesn't mean shit.
Oh,
you look so handsome tonight.
Oh yeah.
I crushed him tonight,
everybody.
I went out and finally gave in to the sport coat life.
This is what I did.
I just saw in the pocket square life,
I decided that I was going to out French the frog.
Fuck these people with their fucking,
you know,
slick way of dressing.
And it went out and I got this fucking coolest sport coat with the pocket.
Square,
the fucking shirt.
The pants look so good.
I was killing it,
killing it.
And then what happens tonight?
We went out,
we got to that,
that fucking,
that restaurant.
They had no reservations.
We had no reservation,
all no reservation.
Then we were like,
can we say,
can we sit reservation?
And we say,
can we sit at the fucking bar chief and shed?
And they let us sit up at the bar.
We had a great uh,
a great dinner and like the head chef was there and he had these fucking
unbaked,
unbelievable tattoos,
beautiful tattoos,
great work.
We taught with chatting them up about that.
Next thing you know he's hooking us up with shots.
Two rounds of shots.
Have you guys ever had Keno?
Viacom?
Nobody's ever had that.
I've ever had keynote with [inaudible] was really sounds like some whole foods
hippy dippy and noise out of fucking horrific.
I didn't want it and he said it.
I didn't want.
And knowing if someone said [inaudible] don't even just want to like slap them
in the face.
A little burlap sack like as is the dumbest thing you've ever heard of.
But it turns out it's delicious.
It tastes like water,
which is the way vodka.
Yeah,
I got a minute.
We did two not rubbing out cause we did two quick shots and I didn't feel
anything but I feel like I got a nice little buzz going on but not so much that
I'm going to,
you know,
do something stupid.
I think I'm such a booze bag that I wouldn't have done like another four.
That's also true to feel anything.
You've been a bull's bag for the last 10 days though.
Now last 10 days it goes back to the southern tour and then the ninth 19 shows
in Boston.
And then I sobered up.
Didn't fucking do shit just because I had the helicopter thing.
I got that behind me.
And ever since then,
Jesus Christ.
So what happens when we go back home to my eye?
We bought dry out or dry out.
We're going to dry out.
We're going to exercise.
We're kind of like,
do you know what you want?
I want right now.
You don't want,
I want,
I want to fucking the regular cheese.
No,
I want a giant fucking Poland spring.
I want to like two of those.
You know those dumb hats had drunks were at football games and in the 80s where
they had a beer in each one,
I want a giant water.
Oh,
and the two comes down to your mouth and you can drink it out of the,
what is the point of that?
Just for funsies and silliness and did it well.
I don't that kind of cheap to me.
Yeah.
Well I don't think that when they sold it to grown men,
as dumb as it was,
they said this is just for funsies.
Hey guys,
this is just for funsies the next time you're drinking.
Um,
so anyways,
not reading about Silk Road.
Oh,
oh shit.
Look what look what's on.
It's three hours.
What does an ace tracker,
oh,
attracts a,
the quality of ice in different venues.
No,
I'm totally serious.
What do you mean quality?
Well,
look,
if I can put it to where it freezes and then your skied on it.
No quality.
What do you mean?
Well back in the day,
you know,
the Boston Art Garden,
they would have it be a little mushy because Edmonton Mattoon was faster than we
would.
We turn it down a little bit mushy,
mushy,
like the ice,
but you know,
it's a little slushy.
Yeah,
everybody did.
Everybody would do that.
And then fucking Edmonton was fast,
so they would turn this extra called,
it's like Brady had take a little layer out.
Fucking this guy puts a little more air ran.
It was bullshit.
But you're all ice skaters,
so why would you just make it optimal first of all?
And everyone's on the same.
I don't know what,
first of all,
I don't know what ice tracker is.
I just made that shit up.
But no,
but Boston did.
Boston did get accused.
Boston did get accused of,
uh,
of,
of having the ice a little,
little mushy to give him a chance in the beginning of kids have a lot of things.
I,
everybody's getting accused of Shit over the years.
We're just only going to get suspended and find the,
the Bruins didn't get suspended a fine for it.
Hmm.
Okay.
Well now it's dumb.
You'd a week Jim or say put a fucking a banner up at Lucas oil field that said
2014 AFC finalist and I don't know,
maybe he's using again.
I don't know what his deal is.
That's such a low block game will begin soon.
Yeah.
The going to the Internet.
Right.
Which means that they're uh,
showing some Ritz cracker commercial,
but France,
uh,
cause we were talking about the book that I'm reading right now.
Done as it over.
No,
go ahead.
What do you mean?
Like I was telling you earlier tonight that I hate when you try to show me up by
reading,
by the way,
but I'm really late on reading this book.
I'm really laying on reading gone girl.
We saw the movie ages ago obviously.
Uh,
and now I'm finally being the book cause it was here and which one was gone?
Girl.
Are you joking with Ben Affleck or he did gone.
Baby gone in.
Gone Girl.
So gone girl was the one that's good plan.
Yeah,
he directed that was like,
you know Chuck Berry.
You did,
you did twist in the next year.
He came out with twist again.
Yes.
Chuck Berry and Ben Affleck.
Chuck Berry like Chubby,
Chubby Checker,
Chubby checker.
Let's do the twist.
And then a year later he was like twist again like we did last summer.
I feel like we sound like right
junior from a,
what is it,
the Cleveland show
maybe.
Maybe Cleveland.
Sounds like Chuck Berry.
I mean fucking Chubby checker.
My name is Cleveland Brown and I am here to say back in my,
Oh no,
he didn't talk like that now his son dead with son die.
What?
No,
it's a cartoon.
Anyway,
it's just the way he said that.
I thought he was dead.
He was overweight.
I was just saying I was reading,
I've been reading this book and gone girl and speaking of Boston,
I just feel like Ben Affleck couldn't be more perfect casting for the role of
nick cause you've never met him and you've read a bunch of,
I have met him.
I met him and I shook his hand.
Remember
that meeting the guys he walks by don't know him,
but it was perfect cast as he was on his way to knowing,
to talk to people that he actually,
no,
when we follow each other on Twitter are ridiculous.
I don't know him at all.
Flashed your fucking chocolate Brown eyes at him.
Couldn't care less
fucking stupid videos.
What is wrong with you?
You really have the mentality of a 15 year old boy.
Sometimes I swear to fucking God,
fucking gossip rags.
They're getting divorced or not.
What do you give a fuck?
Same video over and over again and falling down
and getting into a fight.
We about Bro,
we'll come at Bro.
All right bro.
Some douchebag holding this Goddamn old ass Samsung.
That's all I watch.
I watch by watch puppies and babies,
so watch those,
those fucking videos.
They make me laugh.
I love watch the ones where the dogs are afraid to walk by the cats.
I watched EDC on an ATV falling up and his friend be like,
no,
I got it.
Totally got.
Anyway,
what do you read the read fucking pink is the new blog does he draws those decks
on everybody's faces with the jazz on?
Is a couple of things wrong with what you just said.
Number one,
pink is a new blog.
Hasn't been,
well,
maybe it's still blocked.
Still have like,
I don't know,
but that was something that I read when we first dated like in 2005 or
something.
Okay.
That's the one.
Yeah,
but you still did it.
The drawing of the digs and things was by Perez Hilton,
and I haven't read that in.
I don't even know how long.
All right.
Well,
yeah.
So what,
how was that better than what the fuck I'm watching?
I don't know.
Well,
there you go.
Then.
I thought fuck is wrong with you.
I watch easy,
fun based stuff with tabs.
100 amazing baselines.
I watched somebody do a Stevie ray Vaughan covered today.
I watched a bunch of Stevie ray Vaughan videos.
I was watching his shit.
I watch,
uh,
what do I got?
A girl knockouts.
Golf fights to the worst because they're just grab each other's house.
Hair's all street fighting
and you go one punch knockout number on the bottom.
That seems numbers in the bottom.
That's somebody's phone number.
That's a phone number.
That's New Jersey Two oh one four oh six it's an actual,
is that 201 billion?
406 million?
No,
no,
no.
All right,
well that's a hundred that's 1,010 thousand a hundred thousand that's a million.
That's 100 million.
That's a billion.
Okay,
that's 100 billion.
That's a trillion.
That'd be 20 trillion.
What is the point of all this?
No,
cause I actually realized I see a number like that and I wouldn't know how to
read it that way.
Well,
it helps if they put commas in it
all.
Okay.
This is all street fighting.
One hitter,
one hitter,
quitter.
Greatest,
one punch,
knockout ever a compilation.
Part one.
Let's watch some of these.
Why though?
Oh,
this is boxing.
Come on.
White to just once.
[inaudible] wow.
Wow.
You barely touched him.
Seriously.
No.
What I call bullshit.
That's some fucking,
you know,
pulp fiction in the suits.
Your ass goes down.
Like that's what that,
that's a Marcellus Wallace.
Take the money and run.
Listen,
whether you believe it or not,
you're already into the video.
I know.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Violence can be enjoyable.
We need to end this thing.
Listen to everybody.
I'm back,
uh,
back in the U S and,
I can't wait to do this tour,
so thank you to everybody who came out to my show so I could take my lovely wife
here to Paris.
I never thank you guys for that,
but it goes without saying thank you.
And um,
and they get everybody who's shown up on this,
uh,
on this next tour coming up.
Uh,
I can't wait to do it and I've never toured this with,
I've done some shows with bargaining,
but I've never gone on a run like this,
so it's going to be fucking great.
And uh,
I'm really looking forward to getting back and seeing all clearly,
oh,
when we get back.
All right,
they go shut up.
Um,
that's it.
you guys have a great weekend and I'll talk to you.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
yes.
He has some conspiracy theory for you.
Somebody said bill that they uh,
he wrote,
they are watching and um,
I got trashed for talking about conspiracy theory.
I've been trashed for talking about those automated checkout lines in the
grocery store and saying that I'm paranoid and I'm afraid of technology and all
this technology's just going to help my life and make my life more easier.
And why don't you trust these big fucking corporations?
Basically it's the shit that people are giving me,
so I have to get trashed for off,
you know,
talking shit about all these corporations and actually having the audacity to
think that bankers,
we're all trying to team up and have one world bank yet up to become the loan
sharks for not everyone,
not only individual but actual countries.
Okay.
Which is something that I was thinking about when I was at the Rose Bowl was
stone sober and I was sitting there on the golf course and I was looking at
these houses up on up on the ridge of this hill that actually looked down on,
on the Roosevelt,
the granddaddy of them.
All of these people have a house that looks down on it
and I was actually envisioning that those were all bankers up there and while
the game was going on and 104,000 people or 96,000 we ever showed up for that
game was sitting there going fucking crazy.
One of those pieces of Shit bankers up there could put his hand on his son's
shoulder and be like,
see all those people down there,
they owe all of us money.
They all owe me money,
son.
I'm getting a piece of all of their fucking paychecks.
And they don't even know it.
They don't even know that their daddy is looking down on him right now.
Now had been drinking
that thought would have probably caused me to,
uh,
you know,
entertain the thought of climbing up that hill and throwing a rock through one
of the windows,
which of course I wouldn't have done because even my drunkest I am aware that I
don't want to go to jail and get raped.
And secondly,
I really,
I'm not going to go all the way up that fucking help.
So what I would've done is I probably would have yelled at that kid with the
light purple slacks.
I would've commented really loud about that dude's fucking,
uh,
Eczema flaking off into the back of his damn sweatshirt.
Um,
so anyways,
this guy sends me this email and he says,
build the vase in this blog.
When I say they are watching our big business,
not the Illuminati,
but they are just as evil as any bank or secret society.
They don't even need your signature.
Listen to this shit.
They don't even need your signature for these information gathering trader where
programs to monitor everything from where the device is to what your heart rate
is.
It's what is trade where.
That's the question I had.
Um,
you digital camera may embed metadata into photographs with cameras,
serial number or your location.
Your printer may be incorporating a secret code on every page at prince,
which could be used to identify the printer and potentially the person who used
it.
Now,
now the fucking morons,
the sheep out there,
it'd be like,
yeah,
that's in case she threatened the president ditches doing it for the good of all
people.
Um,
if apple puts a particularly creepy patent,
I guess Apple's applying for this as a recently applied for the use,
um,
for,
you can look forward to a day when your iPhone may record your voice.
Take a picture of your location,
record your heartbeat,
and send that information back to the mothership.
This is trade aware devices that act behind your back and portray,
portray your privacy.
Now this is what the moron sheep are going to be to say,
well they,
he ain't doing nothing wrong.
What's the problem?
That's,
that's the philosophy.
That was the philosophy behind why they can record your phone calls.
Now,
if you ain't doing nothing,
we're tacy.
You come out frogs gate doing nothing wrong.
Do you realize how fucking dumb that mindset is?
So basically as long as you do what the people in power tell you what to do,
you won't have a problem.
Do you understand how dangerous that is?
Do you understand how fucking stupid it is to have that level of faith in the
people who rule you?
You know what I
mean?
Hey,
you haven't noticed
how much power can fuck somebody over.
Like for some reason we only seem to focus on when celebrities get famous and
then they wig out and start becoming these fucking mini tyrants.
For some reason people don't feel they just have like this because they waved
the flag and they,
they,
and they play those songs that make you choked up that they never feel like that
they'll have any sort of ulterior motive for this.
This is the type of technology
that allows a small group of people to take over the world.
Something that's sociopath's have been trying to do since the beginning of time
and they were never able to do it because at some point your army would be
stretched too thin,
right?
Germans,
the fucking Roman empire,
all that shit.
At some point the fucking Japanese,
all of them,
everybody who's ever tried to fucking do it,
at some point it gets stretched too thin.
So America,
what we've done is we,
then,
we,
we've,
we've done the,
uh,
we're putting this base here to protect you thing,
that brilliant thing.
That's how we got our world empire.
So we just have a base.
Then also we have these insane weapons where we can nuke everybody.
So we were able to kind of do it that way.
But the problem is,
is when you really get into sociopathic thought,
and just like those people who are so into power that it makes it dick hard is
they want to know.
They want to be able to see everybody,
know what they're thinking and know what they're doing at all times because not
only they psychos,
but with that level of power becomes this unbelievable level of paranoia.
Like those people with those houses sitting on the ridge looking down into the
rose bowl,
there's a fear.
Like we sit there looking up at it,
go look at they got the fucking world.
There was a fear of when you attain that level of wealth,
of losing all of it,
and you begin on this,
this quest to quiet your mind,
you want,
you want to get a level of wealth and controlling your life that you are
guaranteed that it will never go away in your lifetime or your kids' lifetime or
your kids' kids.
So basically everybody that you know and love will be okay and you will be okay.
You get into that psychotic fucking mindset and uh,
you give those kinds of people this level of fucking technology and you're going
to have a problem.
I think that's unbelievable.
But that this shit is,
so they have this,
this website here,
uh,
the eff electronic frontier foundation that is trying to fight
these things being put into,
into the detect,
you know,
the cameras,
the cell phones and all that shit.
Like the fact that there's a tracking device in your cell phone.
Like,
how come we didn't get to vote on that?
How come we don't get to vote on that type of stuff?
I don't want people knowing where the fuck I am and all God damn times.
Okay,
and I don't need you to show me,
Oh,
we caught this fucking child molester with that.
So because of that,
now everybody has to be like,
give me a fucking break.
They always have like,
you know,
that there's,
a handful of good examples for that level of fucking control and then does a
zillion bad ones.
So I am 100% against the shit.
And,
um,
there's always been evil people in the fucking world.
There's always going to be evil fucking people in the world.
And when you get,
when you have this kind of technology that you're going to,
you're going to stop.
They're going to stop small,
evil like individual,
you know,
uh,
a fucking a serial rapist.
What?
You definitely want to stop,
all right?
But the price we're going to pay is you're going to allow a Stalin or a Hitler
Pol Pot,
whoever the fuck you wanted that you to leave with that level of technology out
to someone like that could get in power and run the fucking world.
So,
you know,
I dunno,
I,
I
totally 100% believe that you could roll all your fucking eyes all you want.
I honestly believe that.
And I also believe that the reason why there's so many of us right now and that
the people at the top are not fucking concerned about it,
okay.
Is because we're all expendable.
And when the waters rise up,
the temperatures goes up and everything,
they're not going to be the ones who are drowning.
You can guarantee that the user in our taxpayer money to build some sort of
something to make sure that they're okay.
And I think that their bailout plan because they know they can't stop people
from fucking,
because it feels too God damn good and Dixon pussies are readily available to
anyone.
It's like air,
you know?
Okay.
So I think what they're going to gradually do is phase us out with robots and
automated shit,
which is why I refuse to use it now.
How fucking crazy do I sound right now?
Has there been anything funny in the last fucking five?
This is shit that I truly believe.
You know corporations own like the DNA of a grizzly bear.
That's why they don't give a fuck that they're cutting down its habitat.
They're like,
I will fucking grow another one in a petri dish.
We're trying to take over everything and then wipe out.
I think they're going to try to wipe out the poor and the middle class keep a
couple of us,
like a small handful of us.
You know,
the way that pandas are only in like a zoos at this point or some shit.
I don't know.
Maybe I pick the wrong fucking animal,
but that,
that,
that's the direction I think it's going.
All right.
This is your first crazy rant,
which was based mainly in gut feelings in a couple of emails.
But,
um,
I truly believe that
[inaudible]
okay.
Speaking of what do you guys realize that right now,
Brett Farve
is getting sued some of the ship.
How fucked up the world is right now.
Brett Farve is getting sued by the,
uh,
by to Massachusetts because he tried to get,
some sort of sexual favors afterwards and they're,
they're,
they're suing for that.
Okay.
Do you understand that?
Let me say just one more time.
Brett Farve is getting sued by a Mizzou tumor.
Susis does that how he said my son says,
um,
mousses um,
tumor Zzusis for,
for asking basically to,
uh,
you know,
to bang them at the end of it,
there's sewing him.
Can you fucking believe that I just fucking bus that will,
you know what that's like?
That's like me suing a comedy club because I got heckled.
It comes with the job.
There was not any machine,
any female most suits out there that listens to this podcast.
Are you honestly going to tell me that?
That you've been rubbing guys bags and their legs and the chest and all that and
you've,
no one has ever asked you for a fucking hand job at the end of it.
It fucking comes with the territory.
That's like being a cop.
And so when the city,
cause you got shot at
all,
right?
You fucking put hot oil all over a guy's body and you rub everything but their
dick.
I mean give me a fucking break.
You goddamn cock cheeses.
Yeah.
People are going to ask you to rub one out.
Okay?
And if you had a shred,
a fucking decency,
you do what?
You complete the Goddamn job.
All right?
Because you signed says full body massage.
All right,
last I saw my dick is still part of my body.
All right.
You know what they are?
What?
As Susan is a like,
they like the fucking quarterback who can't get it done.
You know,
just always comes up a little bit short.
They should fucking interview them afterwards.
So,
you know,
like what happened in there?
Uh,
you know,
I just didn't,
just didn't get it done.
You know,
it's was like right there.
All I do is just reach out and grab it.
And I just,
uh,
you know,
we didn't want it.
We didn't want it as much as they wanted it.
Um,
that's just like,
just,
that's such a classic,
uh,
piggyback lawsuit.
It's like once that first stupid whore,
um,
you know,
gay Brett Farve Shit,
this is very interesting that I've noticed about horse.
Once one comes out of the woodwork,
then all of a sudden 20 come out of the woodwork,
you know,
and then they always try to paint it as well.
We were too scared.
We were scared.
Fuck you.
You were,
you trying to make money and you're trying to build on the momentum of the other
case.
That's the female version of pulling a train on somebody.
You know,
the guy version is,
you know,
you and 80 of friends,
bang the same girl.
The female version is,
you know,
you're a fucking whore and you're just waiting for a whore to sue a guy that you
fucking banked and then you fucking,
you,
you draft in right behind their lawsuit.
Okay?
You know some of those myths,
Susa State,
and they'll actually come to your house and give you a full body rub down with
oil.
Okay?
And then have the fucking nerve to get upset that you try to get a hand job at
the end of it.
You know,
give me a fucking break.
Why don't you fucking [inaudible] broads man the fuck up and start rubbing one
out?
Is it that God damn hard,
no pun intended.
Is it that fucking difficult
to just fucking,
you know,
it's like you're revving a motorcycle.
That's it.
That's all you gotta do.
Up and down,
up and down with that dead fucking oil.
You in and out.
You want that house on the hill,
sweetheart?
There's a price to pay.
All right?
And when a quarterback who owns every fucking record,
good and bad,
and the Goddamn universe asked you to rub one out,
God damn it.
You fucking rub one out.
Well,
maybe you don't blog in this business sister.
That's right.
Stare at your fucking manicured toes.
Pedicured whatever the fuck you supposed to say.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
[inaudible].